[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
ce premier numéro du 7-8 politique
consacrée aux élections municipales
jusqu'en mars nous recevrons dans cette
émission les candidats à télé candidat
tête de liste au scrutin 2020 dans les
yvelines chaque semaine également un
point sur les différentes campagnes
première invitée othman natrue bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes né en 1987
actuellement conseiller régional d'île
de france président du groupe les
républicains et indépendants aussi
conseiller municipal d'opposition à
trappes vous étiez candidat en 2014 où
vous aviez totalisé au second tour un
peu plus de 30% des suffrages exprimés à
nouveau candidat votre liste engagement
trap est citoyen et la première question
concerne votre couleur politique
j'évoquais les républicains mais ce sera
une liste sans étiquette
oui l'enjeu aujourd'hui à trappes c'est
de construire l'avenir de la ville et ça
passe par un rassemblement de gens qui
ont des sensibilités différentes
bon je suis un homme de droite j'ai
toujours assumé je ne m'en cache pas
mais quand je vois aujourd'hui les défis
qui nous attendent à trappes
je considère que il faut toute une vraie
équipe de compétences avant tout et je
ne te ne prend pas les gens en fonction
de leurs étiquettes et je suis très
heureux qu'on ait aujourd'hui fait
équipe formée un vrai duo avec mustapha
larbaoui qui est un homme qui n'a pas la
même sensibilité politique que moi qui a
la sienne qui lui est propre qui va
garder je veux garder la mienne mais on
est d'accord sur le travail
le projet crédible financer d'ontera pas
besoin pour les années à venir
et c'est ça aujourd'hui qui nous réunit
c'est ça qui sera vraiment l'adn de
cette liste qui sera en réalité la seule
à même de porter un vrai changement pour
trappe une équipe de compétences au-delà
des étiquettes politiques dans laquelle
jacques l'institut repas de soutien des
républicains par exemple peuvent
soutenir tous ceux qui le souhaitent
moi je ne demande aucune investiture
particulière savez en 2014 les
trappistes m'ont accordé leur confiance
avec un score qui était un score assez
important c'est ce qui m'a lancé en
politique
et depuis j'ai pris des responsabilités
et je sens qu'aujourd'hui je peux être
utile et je n'ai pas besoin des partis
politiques là dedans j'ai besoin que les
habitants fassent confiance à un
nouvelle équipe et un nouveau projet
parce qu'encore une fois le quotidien
des trappistes et bien mérite qu'on
sorte un petit peu des questions
d'appareil qui sont très éloignées des
vraies problématiques concrètes dont la
ville a besoin et vous le savez je
défends asafa nombre d'options un
certain nombre de dossiers
au sein du conseil municipal depuis 2000
14 depuis plus de cinq ans maintenant
et aujourd'hui on y mur en capacité de
porter ce changement avec une équipe
encore une fois qui est une équipe de
rassemblement qui ressemble à la ville
est la liste est entièrement constituée
aujourd'hui on présentera sept unis au
mois de janvier bien sûr mais un certain
nombre de personnalités qui viennent un
certain nombre m'ont soutenu d'ailleurs
y compris des gens qui viennent de la
majorité municipale il y a des gens
encore une fois de tous horizons qui qui
nous ont rejoints y en aura d'autres et
le présenteront l'ensemble de cette
équipe dans laquelle chacun garde sa
sensibilité politique mais avec un
projet en commun et des valeurs en
commun où il présentera la liste
uniquement mois de janvier un mot juste
sur les républicains encore vous êtes
assez critique envers les décisions les
orientations prises par le parti au
niveau national aujourd'hui 7 plutôt
proche de valérie pécresse qui a fondé
son propre mouvement libre est ce que
vous imaginez quitté l'est républicain
où c'est une réflexion qui se fera après
les municipales aussi noter aussi j'ai
toujours été très claire et très
constant mois ci les trappistes accepte
de me confier la responsabilité de la
ville
eh bien naturellement je me consacrerai
à la ville et je serai à mr sans
affiliation partisane parce que l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est bien de redonner la
confiance des de nos concitoyens autour
d'un projet qui ne passe pas par des
appareils et encore une fois je garde ma
sensibilité politique je suis un homme
de droite
je le redis mais je ne veux pas être
l'otage d'un parti politique quel qu'il
soit j'aime apporter ma contribution
dans le débat qu'on a pu avoir à droite
ces dernières années en disant aussi
mais différence est imé divergences
parfois avec ma famille politique
d'origine
j'en ai un certain nombre mais en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui une l'enjeu sur
la bulle c'est d'être en dehors des
partis parce qu'une équipe municipale
c'est du concret c'est du quotidien
c'est de la proximité n'est certainement
pas des débats nationaux conceptuels
comme on peut en avoir en ce moment
beaucoup sur les chaînes d'information
donc la réflexion qui était ou non les
républicains ce sera après pour les
autres villes mais je vous regarde très
clairement si je suis maire de trappes
je serai à maire sans étiquette sans
étiquette parlant de ce programme
justement vous parlez des différentes
sensibilités politiques qui vont
composer qui composent déjà votre liste
il faut tout de même se mettre d'accord
sur un programme en commun quelles sont
les valeurs aujourd'hui et kids id 7,7
ce programme par donc vous allez
présenter pour nous les choses sont
extrêmement claires il ya la vie
de la ville qui a changé notamment entre
2001 et 2014 avec la rénovation urbaine
maintenant va falloir s'occuper du cadre
de vie des habitants parce que s'occuper
de la pierre et du béton c'est bien
falloir s'occuper des gens et en
l'occurrence quand je dis ça il ya un
certain nombre de défis qu'ils ne sont
pas relevés aujourd'hui et moi j'ai le
sentiment que cette majorité municipale
dans toutes ses composantes
toute la division qu'on a aujourd'hui
n'est pas en capacité et bien de porter
l'avenir de la ville parce que j'ai le
sentiment d'un fonctionnement qui est à
bout de souffle
ça veut dire que sur la question de
l'école il va falloir faire beaucoup
mieux puisque aujourd'hui du niveau
scolaire dans les écoles de trappes doit
être améliorée savez moi j'ai eu la
chance de faire de bonnes études et j'ai
absolument je suis attaché au fait que
chaque enfant trappe puisse avoir la
même chance c'est à dire d'être dans des
bonnes conditions d'apprentissage et là
dessus c'est quelque chose de très
important pour nous je dis pour nous
parce que mustapha larbaoui en
particulier est très attaché à ce sujet
là il a lui-même il ya lui-même apporter
sa contribution
mais le défi de l'école attrape ces deux
défis majeurs des années à venir sur le
soutien scolaire sur le numérique sur
les conditions d'apprentissage
je les dis est aujourd'hui le compte n'y
est pas du tout je vous donne un seul
chiffre là-dessus on a aujourd'hui être
à plus de 1500 enfants entre 6 et 10 ans
donc à l'école qui sont en dehors de
tout dispositif d'accompagnement
scolaire tous les jours et depuis la
suppression de leur de soutien scolaire
gratuite que nous avions en 2015
ce chiffre a explosé c'est à dire qu'on
a des enfants qui sont tout simplement
pas accompagné et on voit bien que
derrière on le retrouve dans le taux de
retard à l'entrée en sixième qui est 50%
supérieur à la moyenne de
l'agglomération ça n'est pas acceptable
et ça sera notre priorité absolue c'est
un sujet parmi d'autres mais vous voyez
qu'on est sur un projet extrêmement
concret qu'on va commencer à présenter
petit à petit on m'avait dit avec
mustapha larbaoui que nous présenterions
au lendemain des vacances de toussaint
on y est et on va avoir le temps de
développer idée par idées et bien des
mesures extrêmement concrètes
extrêmement crédible qu'on est en
capacité vraiment de mettre en place
grâce aussi à l'appui des autres
collectivités région département
agglomération vous parler éducation
population de trappes 30000 habitants
population plutôt jeune l'emploi aussi
est une priorité
c'est une priorité absolue vous avez
raison la population de trappes qui
population très jeune on a quasiment la
moitié des trappistes qui qu'à moins de
30 ans donc c'est le cas donc un défi
majeur qui est celui de la formation
professionnelle
je vous rappelle que en plus sur saint
quentin en yvelines on n'a plus d'emploi
peu d'actifs
et pourtant à trappes on a plus de
quatre mille demandeurs d'emploi et la
réalité c'est l'adéquation entre cette
offre d'emploi et la demande et c'est
pour ça qu'on a lancé par exemple la
grande école du numérique qui était
normal délégation en tant que vice
président de l'agglomération avec 300
places de formation dans les métiers du
numérique qui sont des métiers qui
recrutent j'aimerais que demain sur
trappe on démultiplie ce type de
dispositif et il va falloir pour n'est
effectivement au moins un millier de
formations professionnelles courtes et
qualifiant proposé aux trappistes et ça
sera là aussi un point important de
notre projet parce qu'encore une fois
les employés il existe mais c'est
l'information qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
n'est pas au rendez vous la sécurité
j'aimerais tout de même qu'on prenne
quelques instants pour en parler sur
cette ville de trappes sécurité là
qu'ils dépassent quelques fois le simple
cadre d'assurer la tranquillité le calme
des habitants au quotidien il est aussi
ses départs vers la syrie et qui sont
arrivés assez assez fréquemment et qui
concerne cette commune de trappes
d'ailleurs on a appris que le
gouvernement avait déchu de sa
nationalité un jeune homme de 23 ans né
à trappes condamné en mars 2018 à quatre
ans de prison pour avoir tenté de gagner
la syrie ça c'était il ya quelques jours
comment vous positionner par rapport à
cette problématique klein est ce qu'une
un maire a le pouvoir aujourd'hui et
dans une commune comme trappe à
d'intervenir pour lutter contre le
communautarisme la radicalisation
un maire a le devoir d'être vigilants et
vous savez que j'ai été un de ceux qui
ont posé ce débat rattrape mais pas
seulement à trappes parce que c'est une
réalité qui n'existe pas 4 ap qui
existent dans toute une partie de notre
territoire qui est en réalité dans tout
le pays ce sujet de la radicalisation
que vous évoquez la réalité c'est que ce
que je n'avais pas supporté à l'époque
ses devoirs des familles de trappes qui
connaît ce drame d'un enfant qui se
radicalise qui tout à coup échappent à
l'autorité parentale qui parfois essaye
de partir effectivement en syrie comme
il y en a eu et que ces familles l'année
aucun interlocuteur
on leur explique circulez ya rien à voir
il ya pas de problème ça ce n'est pas
acceptable et le rôle d'un maire quel
qu'il soit c'est évident d'être attentif
il vient au bien-être de ses concitoyens
et de ne pas se voiler la face ou de
faire la politique de l'autruche mais
simplement d'être un interlocuteur de
premier ressort quand ce sujet de la
radicalisation touche une famille et
c'est encore le cas donc il va falloir
naturellement l'un d'eux aussi qu'un
travail de prévention de sensibilisation
que font un certain nombre
d'associations qui est évidemment
essentiel mais vous me parlez de la
sécurité c'est aussi la sécurité du
quotidien
ils plus volontiers la sérénité la
tranquillité des habitants ce que vous
le savez attrape on a une police
municipale qui ferme à 17 heures parce
qu'elle a aussi n'est pas pensable
puisque du coup les habitants n'ont
personne vers qui se tourner quand il ya
des nuisances des incivilités de
l'ivresse sur la voie publique du tapage
nocturne des rodéos sauvages c'est des
choses qui arrivent dans toutes les
villes eh bien il faut simplement avoir
une police municipale dimensionné comme
il faut pas avec lui agent comme on a
aujourd'hui et qui se déplace à les
coûts des habitants à leur demande 24
heures sur 24
et là aussi ce sera à nos engagements
parce que tout simplement ça participe
du cadre de vie d'une commune quelle
qu'elle soit prochain rendez vous pour
vous sur le terrain ce sera le 3
décembre une réunion publique une table
ronde autour de la réussite scolaire
justement et puis d'ici au mois de mars
vous aurez bien évidemment l'occasion de
découvrir le programme de ce candidat et
de tous les autres sur le terrain au
quotidien ils viendront à votre
rencontre la campagne est aussi à suivre
bien évidemment sur notre antenne merci
othman d'assaut merci à vous d'être venu
pour ce premier numéro du 7-8 politique
municipale 2020
[Musique]
et nous restons à trappes avec la
campagne la présence d'al hira belle
adjoint au maire et aux sports et à la
jeunesse a décidé de se lancer seul il
ne repartira pas avec le maire sortant
guy malandain pourtant lui aussi
candidat très probablement proche de
l'ancien député benoît hamon
porte-parole de son mouvement
générations il annonce vouloir regrouper
la gauche guy malandain fait un très bon
travail mais au terme de vingt ans de
mandat
j'estime qu'il est temps de transmettre
le témoin et qu'il est temps qu'on
s'occupe maintenant des habitants plus
encore que des bâtiments
parce qu'il faut réussir la
transformation de la ville de trappes on
a réussi sa transformation urbaine
il faut réussir sa transformation
humaine j'estime que être candidat à 83
ans n'est pas raisonnable je les dis à
guy malandain
je me sens libre donc de m'engager dans
une campagne pour proposer une dynamique
nouvelle
une énergie nouvelle une mobilisation
des trappistes pour continuer le travail
engagé et nous quittons trappe à présent
pour parler de la situation du modem
dans le département des yvelines
l'information a bien qu'alliés avec la
république en marche au niveau national
veut mener une campagne de manière
autonome dans les départements elle
vient d'officialiser voici quelques
jours son pacte d'engagement pour les
municipales pour obtenir le soutien du
modem il faudra donc que les candidats y
adhèrent c'est pas une élection des
sikhs est loin de là aujourd'hui nous on
veut bâtir des rassemblements et porter
des projets pour les communes avec des
partenaires historiques et des nouveaux
partenaires ce qu'on veut faire surtout
c'est porter des projets citoyens dans
les communes et poursuivre le maillage
territorial pour le pour le mode hamon
et jean baptiste à monique que vous
venez d'entendre par ailleurs tête de
liste à villepreux pour ces élections
municipales ce premier numéro du 7-8
politique consacrée aux élections
municipales se termine rendez vous mardi
prochain et 18h45 en direct je recevrai
nicolas une tête de liste divers gauche
aux clayes-sous-bois actuellement
conseiller municipal d'opposition
n'oubliez pas que la campagne est aussi
à suivre sur notre site internet notre
application mobile 7 jours sur 7 24
heures sur 24 pour y retrouver
reportages émissions et très
prochainement un au débat très belle
soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]